sur quartz of jazz un cheval de race
selle français rare dans ce type de
compétition la loire et n marie-émilie
bretenoux en termine avec le grand prix
spécial
la deuxième manche du week-end pour les
cavaliers de pro est la particularité et
les difficultés de cette épreuve sont
les changements de pieds rapprochés tels
des changements clefs au de temps des
changements pilotant les pirouettes
complète et du passager du piège on
communique avec une nette record et il
faut qu'on soit le plus discret possible
ok ça va être un peu les jambes après
les mains quand on pense y est
pour parvenir à un tel niveau des années
d'entraînement et de complicité sont
nécessaires
les cavaliers et leurs montures sont
observés par des juges internationaux
très pointilleux quand ils doivent faire
15 janvier au temps à chaque foulée et
qu' il y en a 13 où il ya une faute au
milieu voilà ça c'est une faute
donc c'est pénalisé par une faute il n'y
a pas plus compliqué que ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui les transitions du cap et au
passage du passage au café les
pirouettes au galop des changements de
pied à chaque figure d ce qui est plus
compliqué en ondes à l'image d'alexandre
ayache l'élite des cavaliers français
aspirent au plus haut niveau mondial et
la route des jo de tokyo reporter à 2021
reprend dès aujourd'hui m
j'ai eu la chance d'être réserviste à
rio
c'était bien réservistes les vacances
c'était sympa mais c'est pas la place
que je veux pour les prochains donc on
est venu on s'est fait plaisir on a
montré que même après cinq mois de deux
maisons on était là et bien là
anne-sophie sert elle est venue avec
actuel de masse à une jument qu'elle
dresse depuis cinq ans le duo remporte
les deux épreuves du week end et le
titre de championne de france
de bonne augure on y pense depuis déjà
un moment on y pense et l'année dernière
on s'est beaucoup battu pour avoir une
sélection pour pour tokyo donc bien sûr
les jeux c'est toujours un objectif dans
la perspective de tokyo et même de paris
en 2024 pour les cavaliers qui dresse
des montures plus jeunes après des mois
piaffer d'impatience ce retour à la
compétition à vierzon était plus
qu'attendu